the whole thing with california for me
is i live there 20 something years i
love that place i like california is a
place specifically southern california i
can drive with my eyes closed and i'll
know exactly where to go because i know
all the freeways i drove a few hundred
thousand miles when i was
selling insurance policies going north
going south going east everywhere right
in l.a driving but california has
a couple problems with where they're at
right now
people are not
politically getting involved and
fighting back and they're just sitting
there saying yes to it when you live in
a place that doesn't want to hear what
you have to say and it's their way or
the highway you have one of two choices
you either have to become so powerful
money wise influence wise where he can
fight back meet kevin try to do a little
bit you know he tried to go out there
and do some stuff with that so you go
out there and impose yourself or you you
you get behind somebody and you say let
me help him out dude you got to go run
we got to figure something out to get
him in there you're the right guy for it
let's get behind him let's support
somebody or
you sit there patiently saying maybe one
day they're going to change and last but
not least it's what you got to leave now
you say that to somebody from california
that doesn't want to leave they say
things like but that's cowardly i said
be careful saying that why you just call
your grandparents a coward
what do you mean
were your grandparents born in
california no why did they come here
well what does that have to do with
anything they're from mexico your
grandparents are cowards
man
how do you feel knowing your
grandparents were cowards they're not
cowards so why did they leave mexico
they should have stayed in mexico do you
know how conditions were in mexico do
you know how conditions are in
california
what do you think sure so what are you
supposed to do sit there you're in
nevada why are you not in santa monica
yeah you have 300 miles you come over
here this way you save yourself 13.3
what are you giving over there for 13.3
that you're seeing being improving are
you seeing things get better right yeah
so you you would much rather come 300
miles this way
build it in a state that says you keep
the taxes do whatever you want to do
you've created jobs here you're happy
you know so california needs um
uh this mayor caruso is good on what
he's going to be doing hopefully i hear
he doesn't have a lot of support though
i thought when he was running
yeah it seems like he has a lot of great
policies he could bring a lot to the
table but it doesn't seem like he's he's
up the popular vote who says that to you
though pulse okay
and who comes up with those polls i'm
not sure okay so
but the point is like and who shows me
those polls there's only a few polls i
trust right i trust gallup you know for
the most part pew
it's a few polls there's only a few of
them okay fox news poll cnn poll msnbc
poll come on guys let's not get naive
here when they pitch it to us like oh
you're definitely not one-sided uh cnn
poll says 82 percent of america loves
the job joe biden is doing
right you know fox news poll says three
percent of people support what joe biden
is doing
both of them are you know kind of so you
have to kind of take
for yourself but i would say the
following
if a
if some of the most influential people
in l.a
are starting to like this caruso guy
you know and the ones that are not are
the ones that fear that maybe there's
going to be a movement of guys like him
going out there making a change of
course that's going to be scary and they
have the bigger mic the existing
politicians have the bigger mic than the
ones that want to be the politicians the
existing politicians are united and they
don't want other ideas to come into
california but
it's it's it's foolish and it's naive
for californians to think california is
going to be great forever you're you're
naive you go study detroit to see how
detroit was the richest city in the
world and then all of a sudden
where is detroit today when's the last
time you said you're going to go
you know buy a house in detroit there's
a lot of opportunities but detroit's not
going to be the next la or new york
anytime soon so we don't think
la's ever going to lose at all because
it's la well nobody thought kmart was
going to go out of business you know
nobody thought lehman's brothers was
going to go out of business nobody
thought countrywide was going to go out
of business nobody thought a 330 billion
dollar woman was going to be bought out
by a chase for 1.9 billion nobody
thought woman was going to go out of
business just like nobody thinks
anything's going to happen to them but
to to have your first year we have a net
loss to population since 1851
that's 170 years
for you to have your first year ever
since inception
for you to lose people california what
first time i mean you got to realize
there is there's a lot to be said about
that now my understanding that was 2021
2021 yeah could that be a lot of people
moving after the pandemic okay so but
why are they leaving though i would say
more space uh and maybe taking time off
work has opened their mind up to
different opportunities i wouldn't have
left had it not been for the shutdown
and that for me because i had a business
working as a real estate agent when
you're going back i'm not
right so why not yeah but why are you
not going back i love it here that's the
point right so but here's the thing okay
so say a girl leaves you
okay
and she says i'm trying to find myself
i'm soul-searching
but babe i love you
okay if she comes back a year and a half
later knocking on your door saying
you're the love of my life guess what
maybe she was really soul-searching
okay
but if you leave california during kobe
because our friend here graham was
soul-searching
and he go find a new girl called nevada
and you don't come back you were not
soul-searching you found something
better sure so sometimes the scary part
is being arrogant
thinking all of these people are going
to come back and they don't miami go to
miami right now
if you come to miami uh um
property value
skyrocketed rent
up
homes were selling for 15 million
selling for 30 million selling for 5
million selling for 10 million people
moving there from citadel you know
goldman trading
you know singer all these guys that
moved from
dc
chicago new york
did they move there during kobe because
they're going to go back to new york how
come they didn't go back to new york
no when an arrogant guy says the
following to a girl oh she'll come back
she can never live without me
oh buddy there's a lot of people in the
world that are better than you
california let me tell you keep staying
cocky like that until people realize you
know the whole thing we talk about
sheltering yeah you know how we said
it's not good to be sheltered because of
public schools and i said in every
society every city we are in a way
sheltered okay
so
california sheltered a lot of people
the pitch was a great pitch
nowhere in the world you're going to
have better weather than this i mean
look at this the mountains the water the
weather
the beach
this is the greatest place on the planet
so then 10 people started saying that a
thousand people started saying that a
hundred thousand people started saying
that now people are believing it until
they left and they're like the weather
is pretty good weather is pretty good
for vacation but did you take advantage
of weather every day no weather is
incredible at monaco do i want to live
there today no sure weather is great on
a lot of places in the world i don't
want to live there though if you enjoyed
this video i give a keynote a few weeks
ago in las vegas specifically on the
topic of cracking a code to content
creation if you've not seen it click
here to watch it take everybody bye
[Music]